many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism so the question
and it's a really excellent question is
what is the role of the ego or the self
in modern stoicism is it something to be
overcome or is it something to be
embraced so let me give you a very
simple answer first neither it's not
simply supposed to be embraced as it is
nor is it something that is just to be
overcome and left behind and we have to
be careful in thinking about whether
we're identifying the self with the ego
there are a lot of interesting
assumptions and even extra questions
bound up in this question about the self
where the ego and the first of them is a
matter of clarifying our terminology
what do we mean by the ego or the self
and do we actually use them to mean the
same thing that depends on what
conception we have of the ego if we're
taking something from say classic
psychoanalytic theory or some of the
spin-offs in other modern psychology
then the ego is often understood to be a
part of the self rather than the
totality of the self or the subject and
the ego is the part that we're most
aware of the part that we identify with
ego means I in Latin that's a
translation of you know the German ich
as well which is what Freud was using so
if we're thinking about the ego in that
sense we might connect that with our
self-image
with what we think we're like as opposed
to how we actually are how we do engage
with the world or the other parts of the
self so we might want to think about
which term we want to use the other
thing to keep in mind is that often ego
has this pejorative sense like you're
you know just doing things to satisfy
your ego or that's all about this
person's ego meaning it has to do with
with their self-esteem and their
perceived status in relation to other
people or their there again their
self-image which they're attempting to
preserve ask yourself is that the same
thing as the self so that's something
important to clarify from the beginning
the second thing to keep in mind is that
stoicism whether ancient or modern does
think that we have a self and it's
identified in different ways in
epictetus the pro i raices or a
translated faculty of choice or moral
purpose is in fact what you are there's
other things that you are as well but
that's at the very core of your being
it's not conceived of quite that way in
some of the other Stoics who don't use
that term but that that gives you a
sense there is a substantive self for
stoicism now whether there's an ego that
depends like I said on what we
understand by it if we're thinking about
our self-image or our consciousness of
self again the Stoics think that we
definitely have that it could be
mistaken however we can conceive of
ourselves as much better people than we
are or as having an importance that we
don't actually have or misunderstand the
way our minds and our bodies work or any
of those sorts of issues a third and
very important dimension of what's being
asked about here is those subsequent
questions should we embrace or should we
overcome the self or the ego how does
stoicism view it so if we're if we're
thinking about ego in terms of you know
self-image is something that isn't quite
the totality of what we are it might be
something to be overcome it's definitely
not something
simply to embrace you know particularly
if we have mistaken conceptions of who
we are and what kind of being we are and
our relations to other people and how
developed we are and what our values
happen to be if that's the case then we
really do want to overcome that ego do
we want to overcome the self however and
the answer is no from a stoic
perspective we're not trying to get away
from the self as a matter of fact you
can't get away from the self it's the
self that's actually deciding about the
self do we want to embrace the self that
depends on what aspects of the self
we're thinking about stoicism is in
large part about getting a good handle
on who we are surveying you know the
totality of who we are our reactions our
thoughts our views our values our
choices the history that that has made
us what we are our own responsibility in
that and so we don't want to say oh wait
we embrace all of that uncritically as a
matter of fact we may need to carve away
parts of the self that are really not
helpful or are even damaging to other
parts of the self we may have to make
some difficult decisions so stoicism is
not going to either embrace or overcome
the self entirely so what is the stoic
attitude towards the self this is a very
important fourth dimension of what's
being discussed in this question
stoicism is a teleological ethics that
means that it has an understanding of
ends or or purposes or goals
telo that thought la right this is what
we get teleological from and it thinks
that we human beings not only engage in
projects that have goals or ends but
there is also a goal or end for us to be
a fully developed fully realized human
being and that would mean to have a self
that would be you might say free of
inherent internal
traditions and conflicts a self that has
developed the virtues a self that truly
understands its place in the universe
and its relations with other people and
beings and behaves accordingly now
notice I used that word self there so
stoicism you can say has a teleological
conception of the self of what a fully
realized human nature would look like at
least an outline because this is
extraordinarily rare
but it does give us a way to make
progress in that direction and part of
the way in which we do that is not just
going on a journey but by looking within
by observing our own reactions on that
journey and making oftentimes tough
decisions about what parts we're going
to keep and what parts we're going to
try to get rid of or at least you know
put into the background so stoicism is
adopting a third stance neither
embracing nor overcoming but rather
transforming the self by the very use of
the self into what the self is supposed
to be if you found this answer helpful
for you then please share it with others
who might benefit from it this work is
entirely supported by crowdfunding on my
patreon site so if you find it valuable
consider becoming a supporter at
patreon.com slash Saddler